foreign
[Music]
yes thank you for that introduction it's
a pleasure to be here today uh to be
representing Nana string and to be able
to present on uh some of our automated
workflows uh that have been co-developed
between both nanastring and Leica
biosystems combining the high Plex
multi-ohmic profiling ability of the
geomix digital spatial profiler with the
automated uh sample prep system of Leica
biosystems on their bond RX and bond rxm
uh for those who aren't familiar with
Dana string uh we launched our first
platform back in 2008 which was our
encounter system for doing bulk gene
expression uh in uh clinical grade ffpe
tissue
and we entered the spatial World in 2019
with the launch of our geomax digital
spatial profiler which was our very
first spatial platform
and since then we've made it our mission
to map the universe of biology spatially
and we believe that uh the next great uh
round of Diagnostics as well as the next
great round of Therapeutics will be
discovered utilizing platforms like
geomix uh spatially and that is because
biology is extremely spatially
heterogeneous uh just take something as
complex as the tumor microenvironment uh
in this case what we're highlighting
here is a publication out of Dr David
Grimm's lab uh he's a professor in
pathology at Yale School of Medicine
and he's trying to understand
uh in a non-small Cell lung cancer
cohort uh potential uh responders or
predictors biomarkers of therapeutic
response to checkpoint inhibitor therapy
um there's obviously a lot of promise
now uh in immuno oncology with
checkpoint Inhibitors we've made great
strides over the last 20 plus years now
with these Therapeutics but but still
um it's still not entirely clear which
patients will respond positively to
these treatments and which will not
respond positively so Dr REM
understanding that heterogene
heterogeneity of something as complex as
the tumor microenvironment understands
that spatial tools become a bit of a
requirement to piece apart and
understand these predictive biomarkers
not at a bulk level
um such as bulk rna-seq will give you uh
or mass spec but to understand these
biomarkers within their spatial context
and how that spatial context relates to
response to treatment and so in this
case being able to use a platform like
the geomix digital spatial profiler
helped Dr Rim in his lab
accelerate their discovery of potential
predictive biomarkers that they can then
focus on and bring into the clinic in
the future so these spatial tools with
all the allow you to have all the power
of you know your high Plex profiling of
a bulk rna-seq or mass spec but now
allows you to do that with Once once
again conserving that spatial context
and so these tools have really helped
you advance our understanding of spatial
heterogeneity and the role that it plays
within a lot of these different disease
States or therapeutic um States
and so as I mentioned nanostring has
made its mission to understand and
resolve spatial heterogeneity using our
uh our different spatial systems
um geomix is what I will focus on today
that's the system that we launched back
in 2019 and it is the platform that
allows you now to look at multicellular
functional units of the tissue but
profile them with unbiased Plex all the
way up to the power of the entire
transcriptome so
spatial biology actually forces you to
understand not only the X Y uh and Z
spatial resolution of your of your
system or tissue of interest but not
only uh where cells are located uh who
their neighbors are but also what are
those cells doing
um how are they interacting with each
other which pathways are being activated
and so both resolution as well as Plex
become a requirement for understanding
spatial heterogeneity and piecing apart
things as complex as say the tumor
microenvironment and so as I mentioned
geomix allows you to do that on a
multicellular extremely high Plex uh
level and then more recently we just
recently uh launched our cosmics spatial
molecular imager and what cosmics allows
you to do with the power of Imaging is
to do extremely high Plex analysis of
your tissue but to have that resolution
all the way down to both single cell and
subcellular resolution so while geomix
allows you to do hypex profiling very
quickly with the power of the whole
transcriptome in these multicellular
functional units cosmics allows you to
understand which cells are present at
both single cell and sub-cellular level
using hypex molecular Imaging
so both of these systems hand working
hand in hand really give you full under
a full understanding of your biological
system of Interest
and so this is just really summarizing
our spatial portfolio as it stands today
both our geomix digital spatial profiler
as I mentioned for doing the whole
transcriptome and a higher throughput
multicellular profiling
uh and this is really important for when
you want to understand uh the difference
in expression of spatial or functional
structures across a large cohort of
samples
uh and then that's complemented by our
cosmics spatial molecular imager which
allows you to look at up to about a
thousand Plex currently but at both
single cell and subcellular resolution
um and therefore giving you a finer
granularity of resolution for
understanding uh not only the cells that
are present but also the expression
level of different targets within those
individual cells
both systems are automated uh they both
have ffpe capabilities because we know
administering how important it is to
work with clinical grade tissue
specimens and and what cus and what most
of our customers have access to in the
lab today
uh they are also both multi-omic so they
both have the ability to look at both
RNA and protein together and that's also
important as we try to understand
um that kind of central dogma of
molecular biology and whether or not the
presence of the RNA transcript actually
translates over to the functional unit
of the tissue or cell which is the
protein
and so uh by utilizing both of these
platforms together as I mentioned you
really get a clearer understanding and
picture of the heterogeneity within your
biological sample
um I mentioned previously uh the tumor
microenvironment in this case what we're
showing you here is actually a mouse
cross-section of a mouse brain and in
this case if we're interested in looking
at the hippocampus for example which is
um circled in the center there we can do
kind of multicellular whole
transcriptome entire pathway profiling
utilizing the genomic system on the left
but then also understand what cells are
present and what their cellular state is
by using hypex molecular Imaging on our
Cosmic systems on the right so with both
of these platforms understanding both
which cells are present but also what
those cells are doing and both require
these two unique capabilities
as I mentioned I'll Focus mostly on
geomix today because our automated
workflows uh using the the bond RX and
rxm have been pre-validated and tested
currently on the genomic system
um so we have a really nice integrated
workflow between both the Leica system
and the nanostring geomix uh so I'll
focus on those today but first I'll take
you through some of the similarities
between both platforms as well
one of the main similarities as I
mentioned is both of these systems have
been designed to give our customers uh
ultimate flexibility with what samples
they can profile or image um using their
nanostring systems
both have a wide area of scanning and
that gives uh investigators flexibility
to work with things such as core needle
biopsies whole mouth tissue sections
obviously both of these platforms have
been ffpe validated so they work both
with ffp but they also will work and we
do have pre-validated protocols for
fresh Frozen tissue as well and then
finally because they both have these
wide scan areas they allow our customers
to also work with things uh like tissue
microarrays where you can put multiple
samples uh on a single tissue section or
on a single slide to utilize piplex or
higher throughput of the numbers of
samples that you can look at at a single
time
for the geomix platform uh to do our
profiling rather than attaching
fluorescent probes uh to antibodies for
protein detection or uh in in C2 probes
from RNA detection what we've actually
done is come up with this uh DNA oligo
barcoding system which allows us to
Multiplex with all of the Power of
Illumina next-gen sequencing with the
numbers of targets that we can look at
at a single time so we're no longer
limited by the fluorescent spectrum of
our microscopes for being able to do
spatial
um multiplexing we now can utilize the
power of next-gen sequencing and as I
mentioned we have a partnership with
Illumina to do this where we can utilize
their platforms now for doing hypex
multi-omic detection using our geomix
system
as mentioned for protein it's all
antibody based so these are IHC tested
and validated antibodies we use standard
immunohistochemistry protocols for doing
all of our staining and that's what
allows us now to also utilize uh the
bond system uh for putting that
automated staining protocol on that
platform
uh the unique capability here is not
only the DNA barcodes that we're using
for the multiplexing but also these UV
photo cleavable linkers that are
attaching those oligo barcodes to the
probes and what's unique about those
photo cleavable blinkers is they allow
us now to stain up an entire tissue
section with a almost an unlimited
number of these targets uh and then
utilize the UV power of the geomix
system to cleave off those photo linkers
uh photo clickable linkers and release
those DNA barcodes uh into a little
liquid bath that's sitting over our
tissue uh for doing uh aspirating and
then Downstream analysis of those oligos
uh on next-gen sequencing
so as I mentioned multi-yomic uh
utilizing uh antibodies for protein
detection and NCG probes for mRNA
detection
and uh and we're just using standard
immunized chemistry protocols as I
mentioned uh we are combining those
oligo tagged uh probes with uh up to
four fluorescently labeled probes and
the reason we do this all on the same
tissue section is that those four
fluorescently labeled probes allow us to
actually visualize the tissue section on
the geometric system so kind of at its
core of the geomix platform is a
fluorescent microscope it allows you to
visualize up to four fluorescent
channels on that uh tissue section but
layered on top of that fluorescent image
are also these oligo tagged probes and
barcodes so we combine all of those both
Imaging reagents and profiling reagents
onto a single tissue section all using a
single antigen retrieval and one single
stain and then once those are combined
then that slide is ready to go onto the
G the DSP system uh that antigen
retrieval uh and staining has been
automated as I mentioned on the Leica
biosystems Bond RX so it allows us to
take a workflow which can take a very
long amount of time a few hundred
minutes of Hands-On time for doing all
the dewaxing and deparifinization and
engine retrieval and standing and it
actually combines it down now to about
less than 30 minutes of Hands-On time
um uh utilizing the power of that Bond
system so really great automated
workflow and once again kind of
integrates right into nicely standard
pathology labs and workflows
so this is that uh workflow once the
once that slide goes on to the geomix
system uh what's happening on that
platform as I mentioned the system is
going to go through and do a scan of the
Four Color fluorescence uh those Pro
those Imaging reagents that were
included with the cocktail of probes uh
once we've scanned those four color
fluorescent probes uh the system uh will
give you a fluorescent image the end
user then can go through and using uh
that fluorescent image select key
structures or compartments or areas of
the tissue that they want to profile
and they can go through in the software
they just kind of click and drag the
areas of the tissue that they want to
profile and then they hit run and the
geomix will go through and it will move
the objective field of view of the
geomax over the first region of Interest
so one of those first circles that you
see there uh it'll turn the UV light on
right through the objective of the
geomix system and that will release
those photo cleavable linkers and
release those DNA barcodes as I
mentioned into a little bath that's
sitting over top of the tissue a micro
capillary system will just come by once
those uh oligos are released and
aspirate them up so a little micro
capillary system aspirates up those
oligos that were released from the
tissue and it will dispense them into a
single well on a 96 wall microtter plate
where uh each well on that plate has
been indexed back to the X Y area on the
tissue of the region that was selected
so we are actually connecting based off
of The Well of the plate the X Y area of
the tissue that we're profiling that's
how we're combining now the multiplexing
with the spatial information
uh the system will go through through
each region that was selected one at a
time until either you filled up the 96
well plate uh or you've exhausted the
number of regions that you've selected
on your tissue
uh that plate then comes off it will do
kind of a very simple standard Library
prep on the plate uh and then those
oligos are pulled and they can be read
out either on our encounter system which
will allow uh for targeted readout of up
to 96 targets at a single time
or on Illumina next-gen sequencing where
once again we can go all the way up to
right now currently about 22 000 uh
probes at a single time
um using the power of next-gen
sequencing
once that data has been read out uh it
gets ported back into the geomix and
that expression level data gets mapped
back to the XY area on the tissue that
the regions were selected on so there's
just an example of a tonsil on the
bottom right hand side there that you
see and you can see germinal centers you
can see the T-cell beds and the
epithelial layer in green and then those
regions those circles were selected
across that tonsil and what we can do is
compare the digital expression of a
handful of these protein Targets in this
case back to the regions that they were
selected on the tissue and we can see
that they actually match up really
nicely
and so because we're using UV light uh
to release those oligos from the tissue
we basically have the flexibility of how
fine uh or controlled we can we can
control that UV light to select
different regions across the tissue and
we have tons of different uh
capabilities
um and different questions that we can
answer utilizing this platform
um so anything that doesn't receive UV
light will not actually uh be profiled
uh you'll have the fluorescent image of
the entire section of the entire slide
but only for Regions that you selected
for doing your profiling will you
actually have that multiplexed
expression level data and so if we're
just selecting geometric circles or
squares for example we can ask questions
about X Y you know one area of the
tissue comparing expression versus
another
um so for example if we just want to
drop a circle over you know say the the
tme the tumor micro environment we can
do that and just profile everything
within that Circle
uh but say for example we want to look
at the expression of potential
biomarkers within specific compartments
of the tissue so say we want to look at
expression of uh potential biomarkers
within the cd45 positive compartment so
lymphocytes or say we only want to look
at the tumor compartment we have this
ability to actually control our UV light
to only profile specific cell types or
compartments based off of com that
combination of those fluorescent markers
so in this example we're showing you
here for segmentation that yellow area
uh is a pan side of keratin stain so we
can profile only the pancetta keratin
positive cells and then it's binary so
we can take the inverse of it as well
and profile everything around the pansy
K positive cells this allows us to have
finer cellular resolution and
granularity to really understand where
the expression of these targets is
coming from
and then take that one step further and
say there is a definition of a specific
cell type that we want to profile I
mentioned cd45 and pansck but maybe you
only want to look at macrophages for
example and so we can include say a cd68
stain to only profile macrophages or we
want to look at CD3 positive cells and
so any combination of those four
fluorescent markers can be used to
create a gating strategy to look at
expression level profiling and data of
those cell types
uh if we want to look at expression
gradients so uh similar to the uh the
geometric we want to take it one step
further and look at different layers of
expression as we go from point A to
point B uh in space we could do that by
drawing these really cool unique
um uh expression gradient layers and
look at expression as we go from one
area of the tissue to the nut to another
and just to see how that expression
changes as you go in the X and the X and
Y and then finally if you have no
spatial question in mind other than just
you want to look at overall expression
and understand you know across this
large area what the expression of these
targets are we can do gridded profiling
as well and the system allows you to
just kind of set your gridding criteria
so how many boxes do you want and then
just drop them right over that your
tissue and do kind of high Plex uh High
region profiling uh using this kind of
unbiased gridding approach
so lots of flexibility on the system and
and the reason we can do this and the
the unique capability of the geometric
platform that gives us this ability to
select these specific phenotypes um or
cell types of interest uh are these
little digital micromere devices that
are built right into the microscope so
these DMD uh digital micromere devices
they actually allow us to control UV
light in little one micron increments so
we can set this getting criteria based
off those fluorescent markers as
mentioned those Imaging reagents that
were including in our cocktail
and then once we've set this gating
criteria those little dnds will
reconfigure based off of the criteria
that you've set in the software so in
this case if we want to look at you know
the tumor cells those will be pancetta
keratin positive we'll set that gaining
criteria those dmds will reconfigure to
only shine UV light on anything that's
PNC K positive and then say we want to
understand the immune microenvironment
around the tumor if we've got a cd45
stand which we typically use in our
Imaging reagents we can set that gating
criteria for cd45 positive pansy K
negative and we can profile all of the
immune cells that are adjacent to or
around the tumor and so what this allows
us to do is once again just have finer
granularity into these unique expression
level profiles of these different
compartments
um so where bulk rna-seq is going to
just give you kind of overall expression
you'll be kind of
um uh immediate you'll be
impacted by averaging effects going
across that large area or large tissue
with this capability now we can not only
conserve the spatial XY but we can also
select specific compartments to
understand that the signal that we're
seeing can specifically be contributed
to those compartments or cell types
and so it's been a really uh We've
launched in 2019 uh we've had a lot of
early success with the geoming system
just being out there in customers hands
uh and where we've really found a really
strong value for the system uh is in
these really large uh cohort uh analyzes
where we want to not only conserve the
spatial information but we also want to
understand all the underlying mechanisms
and all the different Pathways that are
being activated within the within the
biological system and so this is now
between the geomix being able to do kind
of larger cohort studies and combined
with the automated ability and high
throughput of the bond RX and rxm system
and then the high Multiplex and pooling
ability of next-gen sequencing
we can really now start to enable uh
High cohort spatial Precision medicine
and really start to understand how these
potential biomarkers uh uh are impacting
uh a patient outcome uh and how
different patients are responding uh to
different drug therapies or treatments
and so uh you know in order to do this
type of large cohort analysis obviously
you have to have a lot of samples uh and
you need to be able to not only get
through all of those samples in a
reasonable amount of time
um but you also need the reproducibility
and quality of data uh that the once
again the bond RX plus the geomix uh
allow you to have because it's cutting
down on a lot of the variability that
can happen with a lot of the different
Hands-On time between multiple steps so
by automating this process and having a
really great throughput on all of these
platforms we really can now start to
enable this type of precision medicine
work
and so
um this is just showing you a little bit
of a comparison on uh the three
different workflows that are enabled uh
using the geomic system the first one is
manual it's about three and a half hours
of Hands-On time to do uh sample prep so
anyone who's done you know kind of
tissue work in the past immunohist
chemistry you understand that you you
know you've got to do your baking your
dewaxing antigen retrieval uh there is
an overnight hybridization step for both
protein and mRNA staining um so we do
allow those probes to sit on the tissue
overnight and then the next morning you
come in you wash the excess probe way
you input your Imaging reagents or what
we call morphology markers and then you
can put it on the geomix system it's
about three and a half hours Hands-On
time
um so not uh incredibly difficult but
still lots of steps and lots of room for
variability within those steps what's
nice about the bond system once again
you can automate so we have both a
semi-automated which does all of the
baking de-waxing antigen retrieval
proteinase K treatment but uh leaves
manual uh staining for the overnight
Hive and then coming in and washing the
next morning so you will need to
manually stain using the semi-automated
but all of the kind of pre-tissue work
and treatment is automated on the bond
RX which is really great because that is
that is pretty labor intensive but
what's really fantastic is this newest
fully automated protocol that we
launched like I mentioned a few months
back that that takes all of that the
dewaxing the antigen retrieval as well
as the overnight staining and the
washing and does all of that directly on
the bond RX system it takes the Hands-On
time all the way down to about 30
minutes and what that does is it
actually opens up your morning so
instead of coming in in the morning with
both the manual and semi-automated uh
and then doing your wash and then your
morphology markers
which can take some time in the morning
and not really getting on your geomic
system until the afternoon with the
fully automated now you can actually
show up first thing in the morning and
your geomix is ready to run you're ready
to take those samples right off the bond
put them on the geomix and that just
opens up more hours in the day for you
to run your geomix system so really nice
three options for the workflows as I
mentioned kind of advantages for all
three here
uh
a little bit more on the advantages this
is really breaking down those times in
specific numbers so you can see how that
Hands-On time breaks down between the
manual the semi-automated and the fully
automated like I said kind of 30 minutes
of really just for the fully automated
about 30 minutes just setting up the
equipment and then once you come in the
next day after the hybridization you
take those samples off and you put them
right on your geomix so it just opens up
more hours in the day cuts down on your
um on your full-time employee time
um so you know it allows you to be more
efficient and it also has some really
nice advantages for things like
reproducibility and the quality of data
as well
what's nice about the fully automated
protocols we have come out with some uh
pre-validated and pre-tested
um panels that work right out of the
gate with both the manual and fully
automated uh and so we've um we've
configured these to work with either
workflow uh but we do have special kits
available for both manual and and fully
automated uh and one of them is our
whole transcriptome Atlas so our WTA
hold transcriptome Atlas
um this is our one of our our biggest
sellers our best product and and the
reason being is it gives you that kind
of unbiased ability to look across the
entire transcriptome for both human and
Mouse
um and so you can look uh it's a
non-poly poly pull down
um so these are probes that will
hybridize to your target rnas so as I
mentioned by not utilizing the poly a it
um it removes that poly a bias that we
can see for just targeting like the
highest Express genes so it removes that
um that a pull down bias and allows you
to use the the hybridization ability uh
of the probes uh to Target uh and get
good sensitivity across a large dynamic
range of both high medium and low
expressed genes uh it's got complete
coverage so it is the entire
transcriptome uh these are all of the
protein encoding genes in the
transcriptome uh they can be combined
with the visualized visualization
ability of the geomex so including your
morphology staining uh for doing Roi
selection as well as cell type or
compartment profiling uh as I mentioned
there are streamlined workflows in that
we have pre-configured kits that work
with both manual and fully automated
um so regardless of what options you
have available to you in the lab we do
have pre-configured kits for both
uh they do allow for customization so
you can spike in uh specific probes that
you're interested in say for example you
want to look at TCR probes uh or if you
want to look at non-coding non-protein
encoding genes you can Spike those in
through custom through our custom
capabilities
uh and because it's non-poly poly a uh
because you can select the biology of
the tissue that you're really interested
in there are minimum sequencing
requirements and um it is a really nice
cost effective option versus some of the
other you know kind of like uh gridded
uh poly a based approaches that are out
there so really nice cost-effective
option as well
um for just focusing on the biology that
you're interested in and we do have the
ability to do to do our whole
transcriptome with protein goat code
detection so our morphology standing uh
for visualization we do have protein
options for that so that can be combined
with our whole chains crypto but we also
have our hyplex profiling ability that
can also be combined on a single tissue
section for both hypex protein and whole
transcriptome profiling from that single
tissue section we call that workflow our
proteogenomics workflow uh there is a
white paper with um uh that workflow
outlined on our website uh so definitely
visit the reagents section of our geomet
X web page on our website if you're
interested in doing code detection for
both RNA and protein together
and so you know kind of now bringing it
all together this ability to combine
whole transcriptome kind of unbiased
pathway profiling with uh the spatial
resolution that geomix provides at the
cellular level allows you to do some
really amazing things this is just a one
example of a data set that is available
on our website to download uh we have
what we call our spatial organ Atlas
which is a series of publicly available
data sets on our website in case you're
kind of curious to see what genomics
data looks like or if you want to
download the data just to get a sense of
you know how we approached our spatial
studies and what kind of Pathways and
targets are being expressed Within These
different unique regions of the tissue
but this is a really great example this
is a pancreas tissue that we profiled
using the geomic system and we wanted to
look at these unique little structures
they're called the eyelets of longer
homes they represent about five percent
of the total pancreas so once again if
you're doing kind of an a gridded
approach to a pancreas you may or may
not land on one of these you'll be lucky
if you do and you're going to wind up
spending a lot of money profiling things
that you probably don't care about but
if you are interested in islet biology
you know geomix allows you to just go
right in identify the eyelets using that
fluorescent staining and then just
profile them with the power of whole
transcriptome and not just profile the
entire eyelid obviously we can do that
but you can also piece apart the unique
cells that are within that eyelet so in
this case we're looking at these Alpha
and beta cells and we're profiling those
Alpha and beta cells with our whole
transcriptome Atlas and we're looking at
the expression of all of these different
targets Within These unique compartments
to understand functionally and
biologically how these two cell types
Within These eyelets are different and
otherwise obviously if you had a lot of
samples you can understand how the
eyelets and beta cells interact across a
large cohort as well ngos gives you that
ability
uh we this is a little bit of an
overview on that um as I mentioned those
pre-configured kits that we have for
using the bond RX and rxm systems uh we
have the human whole transcriptome Atlas
as well as the mouse hole transcriptome
Atlas
um you can also include Uh custom
spykins into both of those uh and we
have our cancer transcriptome Atlas as
well which is an 1800 Gene panel
um so obviously not um as high Plex as
our whole transcriptome but 1800 genes
of the key functional uh targets within
cancer biology so that has been a
curated panel in case you're looking for
something a little bit more targeted
um and we have these sample prep kits as
well as uh pre-configured morphology
marker kits uh that go along with the
bond RX and rxm system as well
uh and so this is just the entire uh
geomix uh assays uh and and portfolio uh
in case you're interested in utilizing
the geometric system uh as I mentioned
we've got a number of different protein
assays uh these different protein assays
they come in these little modules that
can be added up to get to higher and
higher Plex the most plexing we've done
with protein currently is about 165 Plex
um so very high Plex uh utilizing the
geomix with this modular approach but
you can also mix and match the module so
if you're interested in some of the
targets on the immune cell profiling and
you want to combine them with some of
the targets from the neuro profiling
panel you can do that in the geomax uh
the protein assays give you that
flexibility with RNA we have three
current RNA panels one of them is that
whole transcriptome Atlas that I
mentioned for both human and mouse we
also have our cancer transcriptome Atlas
which is that 1800 Gene panel focusing
on cancer biology and then we have an 84
Gene RNA immune Pathways panel so these
are some of the key immune targets 84
genes and that panel is read out on our
encounter system
finally we have custom abilities for
both spike in as well as Standalone so
if you want to do a custom protein panel
or a custom mRNA panel you can reach out
to us and we can help you design that
panel with our informatics team or if
you are just interested in spiking into
any of our current panels where
obviously we can help you out with that
as well
uh this is showing you once again a
little bit of what's being done on that
Bond RX system
um that is the the baking and the
dewaxing
um the antigen retrieval uh as well as
the blocking and that overnight
incubation uh just a really great
automated workflow and and the real
power of that is in the reproducibility
as mentioned now of course all of our
assays are extremely reproduced
reproducible and the geomix system shows
amazing reproducibility both between
user to user as well as instrument to
instrument
um but I think that what you see here is
with the bond uh RX and rxm it actually
takes it to the next level as well um so
just really amazing reproducibility
scores here uh this is showing you kind
of in a standard console tissue with 300
Micron geometric Roi selected the
amazing reproducibility between slides
as well as between the RX and rxm
systems as well for both protein and
mRNA
and what's nice about the genomic system
especially when it's coupled with the
Leica Bond RX and rxm is that we have
this really large dynamic range we have
about six logs of dynamic range for that
expression level profiling and when you
combine that with um like I said the
minimum Hands-On time and
reproducibility that uh the bond RX
provides you get these just amazing
reproducibility scores and as you try
and you know strive towards you know
larger and larger cohort studies or
multi-system studies or
multi-institutional studies being able
to automate all of this and cut down on
that reproducibility and that learning
curve for new users allows you to scale
the numbers of uh the not only the
number of studies but also the number of
samples that can be run in a single
study
um this is a list of all of the
equipment and reagents that are required
uh for running this protocol so
um you can see here you need both access
to the geomix as well as the bond RX
system and a number of the reagents that
are available uh through Leica biosystem
so if you have any questions on what to
order of course um like a biosystems as
well as nanostring would be happy to
help you identify the right um the right
kits and right reagents
uh and uh we have an entire section of
our website uh dedicated to customer
education so if you're also interested
in looking at the protocols and the
workflows uh we have this section of our
website called Nano nanostring
University or Nano uh and you can log in
there uh you can find all of our white
papers uh all of our workflows
um as well as lots of information on how
to get started utilizing both the bond
RX as well as the geomix platforms
and and so we've seen just this influx
of Discovery coming out of these systems
uh these are obviously new capabilities
uh and are really starting to expand our
understanding of biology and and of the
role that spatial uh heterogeneity plays
within uh different biological systems
and so we've seen a large number of
Publications uh we're actually pushing
almost 200 uh to date so far uh and uh
uh most of that has come in the immuno
oncology space uh but obviously a lot of
work being done now um in neurology as
well as infectious disease and a large
number of covers utilizing the geomix
system have been granted uh because of
just the amazing data and some of the
Amazing Discoveries uh coming out of our
customers labs
so with that said I will just uh
conclude here I want to first um thank
uh like biosystems for having me uh and
yes happy to take any questions that
come up and looking forward to working
with all of you once again to uh to map
that Universe of biology thank you